y 27 semanas este juicio y esta demanda
de johnny depp se da después de que
hambre hubiera escrito un open una
columna de opinión en el washington post
en el que de sin nombrar a johnny depp
se hacía se visualizaba como víctima de
abuso doméstico frente a esta columna de
opinión johnny depp demandó a amberes y
ella contra demandó por 100 millones de
dólares es sin embargo el jurado hoy
dice que pues estas tres demandas de
difamación contra amberger fueron
aceptadas por el jurado de siete
personas y entonces schamberger tendrá
que pagarle 15 millones de dólares a
johnny depp en el juicio sin embargo
también johnny depp tendrá que darle 2
millones de dólares a amber heard a su
ex esposa ellos duraron simplemente un
año de casados en varios meses saliendo
pero entonces las reacciones frente al
caso no se han hecho esperar y mucha
gente ha celebrado en redes sociales
esta decisión a favor
de johnny depp también es reacción por
parte de hambre dijo que se veía
desilusionada que a pesar de su montaña
de evidencia el poder y la influencia de
su ex esposo hayan prevalecido hoy en el
jurado